Baga caught earn a degree in business
administration but her new job involves
a different kind of management in the
spring she joined Ukraine's newly
reformed police force
a further departure from the country's
Soviet era legacy although some people
remain skeptical I don't say they're all
like that but a certain percentage of
people don't want to change anything
they want to live the way they've always
lived they are fine with it
generally speaking however the response
on the street is positive
behind the scenes however resistance
from the old guard is never far away we
are initially denied entry to the police
academy despite the fact that our visit
was pre-arranged but after a phone call
or two we're allowed in the freshly
renovated building is now bright warm
and inviting instead of the previous
tree recorders citizens dreaded 18
months after the anti-government
protests and revolution the reformed
police force has become a visible
manifestation of the new era in Ukraine
two thousand new officers have been
hired a quarter of them female we knew
that a very big percentage of people
would support us but we didn't think it
would be so big and that they would be
so positive about it
we're getting a lot of help from society
at large in her spare time in this case
prior to a night shift she attends extra
training courses basic training took
just three months now the recruits are
being given advanced instruction in
between shifts
medical doctor Anatoly DST has
volunteered to teach for free as part of
the fast-track scheme they are so
different to some extent they looks for
me as some kind of dissidents probably
for post-soviet see the situation
because they carry totally different
attitude to people the new police
officers also undergo psychological
training and do not seem to be lacking
in conviction or commitment and her
colleagues are issued firearms and
patrol gear they believe in the new
Ukraine I think the revolution played
its role here because we spent a lot of
time in the Maidan I can't even go there
now because of the memories of what
happened there
back then we wanted to change the
country and I wanted to continue that
over a hundred people were killed in the
protests in the Maidan in early 2014 as
civilians thought running battles with a
much feared Berkut riot police in the
end the officers shot at demonstrators
with live ammunition Volga cop never
wants to see scenes like that again
after fitness tests she finally heads
out for her night shift Olga and her
fellow officers have been instructed to
keep their flashing blue lights on when
they're out on patrol to reassure
citizens that the police are there to
help
their first assignment is to pacify a
dispute between neighbors on the scene
they find a woman who was clearly
inebriated and out of control Olga and
her partner reach for their handcuffs as
hoped that gesture is enough to calm the
woman down her neighbor didn't file a
complaint so we have no grounds for
detaining her there was her husband who
said he would take her home it's all
calm down de-escalation and one of
Kiev's many concrete housing projects
and then they get a new assignment
an abandoned luxury car the first thing
Olga notices is that the parking permit
expired over a year ago during the
Maidan revolution the money for high-end
cars usually comes from graft and
corruption in our country as you know is
quite widespread that's what we're
fighting against aside from speculation
there's little they can do because the
license plate number does not show up in
their database which is currently under
construction all in a night's work for
the newly fledged police force now
patrolling the capital of the new
Ukraine